لعله يعلن عنه
لاحقا
ليس ثم بيت للعزاء مسمى الان لكن الدفن في
رينج غفر الله لنا ولها ولموتى
المسلمين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد
لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام على
رسوله الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان
محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول
تعالى له دعوه
الحق والذين يدعون من دونه لا يستجيبون
لهم بشيء الا كباسط كفيه الى الماء ليبلغ
فاه وما هو ب
وما دعاء الكافرين الا في
ضلال ولله يسجد من في السماوات والارض
طوعا وكرها وظلالهم بالغدو
والاصال قل من رب السماوات والارض قل
الله قل افات اخذت من دونه اولياء لا
يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا
ضرا قل هل يستوي الاعمى والبصير ام هل
ستوي الظلمات
والنور ام جعلوا لله شركاء خلقوا كخلقه
فتشابه الخلق
عليهم قل الله خالق كل شيء وهو الواحد
القهار قوله تعالى له دعوه الحق قد سبق
لنا ان ذكرنا طرفا من معاني هذه الايه
العظيمه
والدعاء في
اللغه
بالطلب
والدعوه والدعاء في
القران على
قسمين دعاء
مساله
ودعاء
عباده دعاء المساله هو الذي يتطرق الى
الذهن لكل واحد منا لما يسمع كلمه دعاء
دعوت ربي يعني طلبت من
الله واما دعاء العباده فهو كل
عباده فانه يسمى دعاء في
القران
لذلك
قال تعالى وقال ربكم
ادعوني استجب
لكم اسمعوا الايه وقال ربكم
لكم ان الذين يستكبرون
عن
عبادتي لاحظ هنا
و مطلع الايه وقال ربكم ادعوني
استجب
لكم كان المتوقع ان الذين يستكبرون عن
دعائي او دعوتي وانما قال ان الذين
يستكبرون عن
عبادتي وكذلك قال
تعالى حكايه عن
ابراهيم في سوره مريم قال واعت
كم وما تدعون من دون الله وادعو
ربي قال الله في الايه التي تليها فلما
اعتزلهم
وما يعبدون من دون
الله فسمى الدعاء
عباده
لذلك تجد في مثل قوله تعالى وقال ربكم
ادعوني استجب لكم ياتي بعض الصحابه بعض
التابعين
يقول وقال ربكم ادعوني يعني
اسالوني استجب لكم يعني اعطيكم
مسالت وتجد غيره يقول وقال ربكم ادعوني
يعني
اذكرني استجب
لكم
اثيبوبيا
يعني الكلام ان باعتبار ان الدعاء
دعاء مساله نعم اسالوني
اعطيكم وباعتبار المعنى الاوسع والاشمل
للدعاء الذي هو
العباده ادعوني يعني
اعبدوني
اثب اعطيكم الاجر على
العباده فقوله تعالى له دعوه الحق له
عباده الحق ليس
لغيره سبحانه وتعالى مثل قوله
تعالى اتقوا الله حق
تقاته الله عز
وجل هو يتقى حق تقاته سبحانه
وتعالى طبعا الانسان
لا يقوى على ذلك على
ان على ان يعبد
الله حق
العباده يوفي الله يوفي الله سبحانه
وتعالى حقه من العباده هذا لا يمكن
الانسان لا يقوى على
ذلك وكيف ذلك
وانما
يعطى العباده ويستمد العباده من الله
نفسه فهو ما زال مدينا لله لذلك يقول ربنا
تعالى انتم الفقراء الى
الله وله دعوه الحق يعني
له مساله الحق سبحانه
وتعالى يعني حتى
المشركين اذا كانوا في
مصيبه وضاقت بهم الارض بما رحبت او كانوا
في البحر وتلاطم
الامواج فانهم
حينئذ يدعون الله مخلصين له
الدين والذي يقوم بقلوبهم لان انجي تنا من
هذه لنكونن من الشاكرين هذه هي دعوه
الحق الذي يدعو الانسان حينما تضيق به
الارض فهذا حقيقه اعتقاد
الانسان فلا احد في ذاك
الزمان الا ربما
المجنون يعتقد ان هذه الالهه تدعى بدعوه
الحق وانما تدعى في الراحه
وكذلك حصل استغلال
كبير المشركون مشركو
مكه استغلوا غير اهل مكه كثيرا
كثيرا ما تفكر انه كل اهل مكه كانوا
مدينين
لا
اجتمعوا في ذاك الزمن ضد النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم واجتمعوا على الكفر لاسباب
مختلفه منهم
للرياسه ولا يعبا بالديانه كانت الديانه
توحيدا جيد كانت شركا جيد لا يبالي وماشي
مع
الاكثر مثل ابو جهل ابو
جهل لو كانت الرئاسه وكذلك عبد الله بن
ابي بن سلول لو كانت
الرئاسه في التوحيد لكانوا اول
الموحدين لكن الرياسه كانت في ماذا في
الشرك في
ظنهم يعني في ظن
اي ابي جهل وعبد الله بن ابي في ظنهما
ومن
يشاكله
ومنهم
من كفر تدينا فعلا تدينا
كفر
ومنهم من
للمال مثل ابي بن
خلف وكفر
للمال واخوه
كفر للشرك
تدينا
ومنهم ومنهم لكن الذي
جمعهم هو حبهم
للكفر سبب حبهم للكفر للشرك للاوثان
يختلف لذلك تجد كثيرا من القوانين التي
وضعوها
وجعلوا
الناس يتدين بهذه
القوانين قوانين في صالح من صالح مشركي
قريش يعني مثل مثل قصه
الحمس اي واحد يجي من برا قريش وليس من
اهل الحمس ما يقدر يجي يطوف بالبيت
بملابسه لازم يطوف البيت بملابس اهل مكه
منين له ملابس اهل مكه
اشتريهم هذا الحكم اج من مين من التجار
يقينا
وايضا الناس
لهم كذا وكذا ونحن لنا كذا وكذا والناس
عليهم كذا وكذا ونحن علينا كذا وكذا
والناس تو يتهم يكونوا
في منى ثلاثه ايام ونحن يومين والناس
يكونوا
في عرفه كذا وكذا ونحن نكون اقل ولا يجوز
لنا نقف في عرفه مثلا او لا نقف في عرفه
لماذا حتى يتمكنوا
من التراس على الناس والا فهذه كلها ما
انزل الله بها من
سلطان فعلى كل
حال لا
تظن ان مشركي قريش اجتمعوا على الشرك
تدينا بل قد يقال قليل جدا
منهم اجتمعوا تدينا بعد مجيء النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم لان حجته ماذا دامغه
حجته دامغه لا يمكن لاحد ان يرى ايه من
اياته الكريمه
ويبقى في قلبه تيقن او استهزاء به صلى
الله عليه وسلم تيقن من ديانته السابقه او
استهزاء بالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لا
يمكن فعلى كل
حال
هم اجتمعوا على الكفر
لمصالحهم ولا
يزال اهل الكفر هكذا يجتمعون ضد
الاسلام لان الاسلام
مضر لهم ولكه
واستغلالهم فعلى كل حال
قوله تعالى له دعوه الحق بشهاده المشركين
هم يعلمون ما هي دعوه
الحق دعوه
الحق لما يكون
الامر
تفطم وكانوا
في مازق
و يعني الم بهم من المصائب وبنات الدهر ما
الم بهم
حينئذ يدعون الله مخلصين له الدين هذه
الدعوه هي لله له دعوه الحق لا لغيره
سبحانه
وتعالى لذلك تجد الصحابه
والسلف رحمهم
الله اختلفت اقوالهم في معنى دعوه الحق
وهي في الحقيقه في الاصل اقوال متقاربه
فمنهم من قال دعوه الحق التوحيد ومنهم من
قال دعوه الحق لا اله الا
الله ومنهم من قال دعوه الحق عباده الحق
الى غير
ذلك فهذه الدعوه دعوه الحق فهي لله
له
وانظروا كيف جاء له الجار والمجرور متقدما
على
المبتدا يعني الاصل ان الجمله
دعوه الحق له هذه اصل
الجمله مبتدا وخبر دعوه الحق
له لكن جاء الجار
والمجرور الذي سد مسد الخبر شبه
الجمله متقدما على خبره للحصر يعني له لا
لغيره مثل اياك
نعبد الاصل
نعبدك ولا لا في اصل
الجمله
لكن
تقدم المفعول على فاعله لغرض الحصر له لا
لغيره له دعوه
الحق وليس لاحد ولا لشيء
سواه هو سبحانه وتعالى له دعوه
الحق وما سوا مما يدعى والذين يدعون من
دونه لا يستجيبون لهم
بشيء الا كباسط كفيه الى الماء ليبلغ فاه
وما هو
ببالغه وما دعاء الكافرين الا في ضلال وقد
سبق معنى هذا
المثل واما قوله وما دعاء الكافرين الا في
ضلال يعني في
ضياع
الكافرون
الكفر شجره
خبيثه
لها
شعب ومن شعب هذه الشجره
الخبيثه
النتنه الشرك هكذا
يتصور فالكفر اوسع مع
من
الشرك
يعني
بعباره
اخرى كل شرك كفر وليس كل كفر
شرك اذا قال الانسان ما الفرق بين الشرك
والكفر
نقول الشرك اخص من
الكفر الشرك نوع من انواع الكفر اوسع
منا لذلك يقول العلماء الشرك شعبه من شعب
الكفر
طبعا هذا
خلاف طويل بين العلماء الفرق بين الشرك
والكفر بعضهم يقول هي مترادفه وبعضهم يقول
ويقول لكن خلاصه
المبحث ان
الشرك نوع من انواع
الكفر فكل مشرك كافر وليس كل كافر مشرك
واذا فهمت
هذه فانك تفهم كثيرا من ايه
القران فايات
القران تاتي تاره بهذه وتاره
بهذه لكن تفهم كثيرا من
معاني هذه المواضع من القران
فقوله تعالى وما دعاء الكافرين معنا بدايه
الايه في ماذا في موضوع الشرك فسمى
المشركين الذين يدعون الاصنام ويدعون غير
الله سماهم ماذا سماهم كافرين فقال وما
دعاء
الكافرين يقول وما دعاء الكافرين الا في
ل يعني كل دعاء وعباده
واجتهاد
وجد
وكد كل هذا على
الفاضي يذهب سدا في الدنيا والاخره لا
يفيدهم في الدنيا ولا يفيدهم في
الاخره بل هو في
ضلال بل اللغو يفضله لان
اللغو ليس
اثمه كاث الشرك والكفر والعياذ
بالله فدعاء الكافرين في ضلال لكن هنا
سؤال هنا جاءت العباره
عامه وما دعاء الكافرين الا في ضلال
لكن هل
مشرك قريش كانوا يدعون الله ام لا يدعون
الله صح ولا لا لكن المشكله ما كان عندهم
توحيد يؤمنون بالله ويدعون الله ويعبدون
الله لكن يعبدون معه غيره
سبحانه فالسؤال
الله عز وجل
حصر هذا الاسلوب حرف النفي مع حرف
الاستثناء هذا يسمى حصرا وقصرا
وما دعاء الكافرين الا في ضلال يعني كله
هذا من اسلوب
الحصر فكل دعاء هو للكافرين كل
عباده لل للكافرين فهو في ماذا في ضلال في
ضياع اذا عبادتهم
لله هل هذه العباده في
ضلال نقول نعم هي في ضلال لماذا في ضلال
يعني في
ضياع
لماذا لان المشرك لا يقبل
منه التوحيد شرط من شروط قبول العمل اليس
كذلك مثل الصلاه ياتي
احدنا ولا يتوضا ولا يغتسل ولا يتيمم
ويقوم يصلي عالما بذلك قادرا عليه هل تقبل
صلاته لا تقبل
صلاته هل تسمى هذه الحركات التي هي تشبه
حركات الصلاه هل هذه تسمى صلاه في الشرع
لا تسمى صلاه هذه ليست صلاه
لان الصلاه انما
تكون ما اجتمعت فيها عده شروط واركان
وواجبات حتى تسمى
صلاه فهذا الذي يقوم بلا وضوء عالما قادرا
عليه
عامدا
ويصلي هل له صلاه هل صل
ما صلى هل هذه الحركات تسمى صلاه ليست
صلاه لان
الصلاه لها شروط معينه كذلك العباده
العباده في الاسلام في القران في السنه
العباده هي انما تكون
عباده اذا كانت بشرط التوحيد وبشرط
المتابعه يعني تكون على السنه
والا فهذه لا تسمى
عباده كما ان الصلاه لا تسمى
صلاه هي تشبه الصلاه وهذه تشبه العباده
لكنها
مدخوله طرا عليها الشرك فافسدها
الذي يشرك بالله الشرك الاكبر يحبط
عمله
ف العباده انما تكون
عباده بالتوحيد
ولا تسمى عباده بالشرك كذلك الايمان ايمان
الانسان ينتقض
بالشرك قال
ا قوم عاد
ل رسولهم اجئتنا لنعبد الله وحده ونذر ما
كان كان يعبد
اباؤنا فالله عز وجل دمرهم وقال في نهايه
سياق ايات قصتهم في سوره الاعراف وما
كانوا مؤمنين هذول مش
مؤمنين ليسوا
مؤمنين مع انهم يعبدون الله ويؤمنون بوجود
الله الا انهم يعبدون معه
غيره والله الله عز وجل يقول انا اغنى
الشركاء عن الشرك من عمل عملا اشرك فيه
معي غيري تركته
وشركه تركته يعني تركت الشخص وشركه لا
يقبل
عمله فهؤلاء
الله عز وجل حصر الضلال في دعائهم لماذا
وحصل دعائهم في الضلال لماذا ذا لان
اعمالهم باطله
حابط لا تقبل لانها لا تقوم على التوحيد
والمتابعه وما امروا الا ليعبدوا
الله ما وقف عندها ليعبد الله الكل يعبد
الله وانما ليعبدوا الله في حال كونهم
مخلصين له الدين له
العمل حنفاء
يعني في قول عادلين عن الشرك وفي قول وهو
الارجح متبعين
للرسل لذلك قال تعالى وما دعاء الكافرين
الا في ضلال نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين الله سبحانه وتعالى
14 سوره
الر
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى
transation الله سبحانه
وتالى سبحانه
وى
real is of true control and majesty
throughout the
creation he is the only true creator he
is the only true maintainer he is the
only true s king he
theon
له دعوه الحق
اللهون true
worship
true
sulic
الله
‏in in any
way neither can they nor would
they they ne hear them nor can they resp
to
them
‏to in order to reach that to his
mouth yet that water will never move on
its own into that person's
mouth what is meant here is that a
person would sit for instance at the
edge of a
well they don't have a buet they don't
have a means of into the to
‏out b the the come
them this is the parable of those who
worship other
allah beging the water to come to them
and the water doesn't even know that
they exist
‏water doesn't even
know and if it did it could not resp to
them even if wanted
to he
says and the warship of the
disbeliever is but in l but in true
l meaning
that
equs no
‏how matter how ex no matter
how no matter how seemingly safal it
is it equ
zer that
is the
warship ‏is only elig to be
accepted and only considered
acceptable based on a coule of
conditions for instance
if we look
pr we
look condition of
pr we could more accur
purification
‏right
is a condition of
prayer person
makes if they in a state of major
impurity then
they then they are to bath if they have
no access to water then they are to make
that is a prerequisite of
prayer the only one who
is exempt ‏from that someone who has no
ability whatsoever and no means of doing
either ok so this is a condition a
person comes and
says you know i'm kind of busy right now
or i don't really feel it so i'm
just going to pray
without and so they stand and they make
this beautiful
prayer
beautifully take their
time
‏mindful
pr would we consider this is this called
pray i me physically through motion
that look a like
pray but this is
pray and this had no chance being accept
الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏instance cover
his what we know to be indecent people's
view of indecency changes with
time drastically
times الله سبحانه
وتالى صل الله عليه
وسلم
‏ to be considered our private parts
or our for
man his
shoulders and from his navel to below
from above his na to below his
knees and for a woman everything except
for her face and
hands so a person knows that this is
expected of them they know that
‏say you know okay dark out nobody they
pray knowingly without doing these
things that commanded that's a condition
of prayer it doesn't matter what happens
after that point the decision was made
to
not to not fulfill that condition that
pr
accept
الله سبحانه
وتالى
all ter
قراني ‏these are the two conditions the
prit of all worship that be for any
partn
and صلى الله عليه
وسلم gener
andic
even ‏is is even
though did in
fact worship الله and الله that worship
is
considered considered inv why because it
was not based
on being purely for allah without any
part وال اعلم صلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله
رب
[Silence]
العالمين
‏l